my channel is sponsored by keeps which
means we will hear more from them
somewhere in the middle of the video hi
everyone i'm alan welcome to my channel
and today we're doing another q a i do
two of these a month now once every like
two weeks um we do gaming one and then a
personal one and this one
is a gaming one get good gamers first
question let's go rick hayes r said is
it just me or is halo infinite massively
overrated it's not even that good is
everybody just losing their minds
because of nostalgia hmm
couple of things one it's a beta
who's rating it
i've seen like positivity on my twitter
timeline but i don't feel like i've seen
any review scores like i'm not really
seeing ratings i'm just seeing people be
happy two i feel like we have this thing
where we call things overrated and
that's okay
but you have to remember with every
facet of everything
people aren't objective okay like this
is a thing that i feel like i've made
videos about before where i talked about
when i was a professional game reviewer
and how angry people would get if your
review score didn't align with their
opinion and and you just have to remind
people everything is subjective game
reviews are not objective they are
literally opinions they are not even
trying to not be opinions but when we
talk about video games we say certain
things are overrated or i i'm sure i've
said those words colloquially but i
think that what you're actually trying
to identify is just that you don't feel
the same way as some other people that
you've seen and that doesn't make you
any more right or them wrong you just
are different people and thus gravitate
towards different things and like
different things and that
is okay
shockingly third i think it's great
i'm having a wonderful time i
didn't
mess with halo 4 or 5
multiplayer while i recognized that they
were very good um just didn't really
click for me as much whereas jumping
into halo infinite tonight and playing
for like a couple of hours with my
friends and having
the best time even where i'm bad because
i've actually never been very good at
halo much better at a third person
shooter than a first person shooter
because my reflexes suck but um i think
it feels really sharp uh i'm a very big
fan of some of the new weapons and i
think the sound design kind of plays
into how satisfying certain things are
at different game modes rotating through
keep things compelling not that that's
particularly unique but no i i mean i
think it rules i was happy with the um
tests and i'm really happy with the beta
so far and i have no doubt that some of
that is nostalgia like zero doubt but
it's also kind of confusing to process
because the reason i feel nostalgic
about it is because i loved the thing
that i played like i loved halo 3 and
reach and two and one of course all of
the halos all of the og halos so
they were good at the time
so
what would stop it from being good now i
think that halo infinite has aged halo
well while also feeling familiar and the
idea that it's just nostalgia i mean the
nostalgia can only exist because halo
was always good right i hope that makes
sense so yes while i am uh i have never
had any shame in my love for halo and in
thinking that halo infinite looked good
because it reminded me of halo one even
when that first reveal came out and
everybody was talking about it being
ugly i thought it looked up because it
looked like halo
i think enjoying something in part
because nostalgia is completely okay and
doesn't like discount it it doesn't mean
that your enjoyment is invalid or need
to be argued against if that makes sense
not that you did that it's just like
separate conversations that i see all
the time halo infinite having a great
time related i intend to do gameplays
with um followers i've done that with
apex mostly before i think i did it with
gears a couple of times so i will uh
play with people on twitch or whatever
via xbox um so i don't know i'd probably
say follow me on
twitter or instagram i'll post when i'm
about to do that and i'll tell you guys
how you can jump in and we can play
together have a good time zack hayes
said have you tried the new supernatural
boxing workouts yet if you have is just
me or are they way harder than the flow
workouts okay i talk about this a lot
but i will take any opportunity that i
can to continue to talk about it
supernatural is a vr app that i work out
in on a very regular basis and it kicks
my butt i think beat saber is a little
bit more fun supernatural is the one
that makes me the sweatiest it is the
hardest workout and thus
it not necessarily but for all intensive
purposes it's a good workout they just
released a new mode which is boxing um
this is an oculus quest 2 if you didn't
already know and yes i agree it is way
harder i also like it more though i'm
finding it more fun because the
movements are a little bit more
different to beat saber which i already
play really frequently i tend to swap
the two games based on the day and it's
great i'm like super stoked that they
released a new mode i'm having a good
time i'm gonna take this opportunity to
recommend because i do all the time if
you would like to um work out and play
video games at the same time get in
oculus quest 2
get beat saber get supernatural vr play
them
it makes me look forward to cardio and i
have always hated cardio it makes it fun
reaper tv you said what advice do you
have for someone looking to transition
from a job in gaming media to narrative
writing job at a game studio well very
specific exactly what i did
so what i did to go from writing and
games media to writing in a game studio
was make sure that i had the relevant
experience um i went from ign very
intentionally to rooster teeth because i
knew that they had tv shows and films
and animated stuff and video games that
i could potentially um write on
to do more creative writing so that i
could build up that portfolio
and then i did game jams um where i was
a writer so i tried to get experience
just working with small teams over 24
hours sometimes 48 hour period i was
very quiet about those just did them in
my spare time
and then this is a thing that i was able
to do because of my position in the
industry that is not necessarily as
accessible to other people but i feel
like you could still
try if you have a body of work that
proves your professionalism which i
would hope that you have if you're
trying to get a job writing at a game
studio you should have already
established something like i have the
nine years ten years or whatever no it's
nine years of of games media and then my
time studying writing at university um
and i asked to sit in and write his room
so i basically approached a number of
indie studios and asked if i could be in
their writer's room so that i could
see things and that also let me um write
in small capacities um i also offered to
give writing services to smaller games
some of which have not been announced
yet that i have written on which is
basically i i already had a body of work
and i just
took myself way down um to doing a lot
of stuff for free a lot of volunteering
which is the exact same way that i got
my games media career started it's the
same playbook you just gotta hustle
figure out how to get experience so that
when a job opens up that you're
qualified for which naturally i am for
the job that i have um i had a body of
work to prove it but i had also written
screenplays short stories um i had done
a dialogue interactive sequence for a
studio in la that i submitted to santa
monica studios so that i had an array of
samples to prove to them that i could
write in different styles
and i also you know i wanted to work at
santa monica studio because i wanted to
work at a studio that has values that
align with the kind of writing that i am
good at
which is uh often very character focused
so
because that was fitting for me these
samples that i had were very character
focused anyway um so i was applying for
a studio that suited my writing style
effectively i don't think it would make
a lot of sense for me to apply
at a studio that doesn't necessarily
treat writing that way so i hope that
makes sense i hope that helps just get a
lot of experience however you can throw
yourself at it go for it
do all of it i'm gonna go as advertiser
as possible on this one just to try it
out just to have some fun let's do it
it's time to talk about keeps
keeps is a subscription service that
focuses on making it easier and more
affordable for men to treat their male
pattern baldness online is it working am
i doing it keeps has online doctor
consultations with a real doctor with
keeps a licensed doctor will review your
information online and recommend the
right hair loss treatment plan for you
then it's shipped directly to your door
so you never have to leave your couch i
feel like it doesn't sound right unless
i do an american accent give me a second
keeps offers generic versions of the fda
approved medications for hair loss which
makes it more affordable their treatment
plans are clinically proven to stop hair
loss and ensure your hair is as healthy
as possible and of course it's important
to note that there is no magic cure for
baldness but you can prevent hair loss
from happening in the first place the
earlier you take action the more hair
you'll keep keeps treatments typically
take between four to six months to start
seeing results so it's important to act
fast so what are you waiting for find
out why keeps has more five star reviews
than any of its competitors and why
hundreds of thousands of men trust keeps
for their hair loss medication if you're
ready to take action and prevent hair
loss go to keeps.com alona pierce or
click the link in the description to
receive 50 off your first order that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash alana pierce
thank you all for listening treat
yourself love yourself back to the video
aussie hub i said hey legend hello
curious to see if there were any games
limited editions i.e ones that came with
statues models that you wish you had
missed out on getting
nothing comes to mind with a limited
edition but let me tell you i have this
holy grail collectible um that i have
always wanted i think it was just uh
here we go oh this is just for the head
my god um
where are you buddy here here
no i can't even find it oh my god
gta 3 it is um
this so i guess this is technically a
limited edition
it's the grand theft auto 3 10 year
anniversary claude action figure this
right here
is my
my holy i loved this game man i loved it
um
i wanted this
so bad and it's sold out and it's now
thousands of dollars um
and not technically a video game limited
edition
um but it is you know like a a limited
edition
action figure i have just
always wanted oh it was made by sideshow
not by um
not by hot toys apparently which you
know that the
sideshow distributes hot toys to sneaky
mistake to make but yeah fully
articulated one sixth scale action
figure of claude
his original cargo pants and his little
jacket and oh my god 1 500 pieces that's
why it's so limited i just i wanted it
i wanted it so bad
and it sucks that i i don't know that i
can spend three thousand dollars on
something like that but um
limited editions not so much what i tend
to do is if i find a limited edition i
don't buy them um i will just wait to
find a way to pick up whatever the thing
that i wanted from them is so like from
the red dead redemption 2 limited
edition i really loved that they had um
the real world version of
the book that you find in stores like
the the
[ __ ] simple word catalog
nailed it you could buy the catalog the
physical catalog with all the art of
like all the old guns and jackets and
all that so i bought that i just tracked
that down and bought it um and if you
were to buy everything that would be
very cost inefficient you would
absolutely lose money by buying each
individual piece without just going for
the full collector's edition but if
you're just buying like one thing like i
did it it works out pretty well um so
yeah i don't tend to miss out on limited
edition collector's edition type stuff
but i have missed out on some figures
that i really like the other one would
be the first four figures i don't know
how much it goes for now but i mean it
came out forever ago
jmfe95 said what's a game you didn't
think you would like but ended up loving
so i have this like tremendous privilege
um it's a thing that i really love that
i get to do at this part of my career of
being on a lot of awards juries for a
lot of different gaming conventions so
like i've done baftas um i've been on
game awards juries um i most recently
did indycade uh and that's happened more
and more often as my career has gone on
um especially in the last 12 months
since i've been working it will be
exactly 12 months today that i've been
at santa monica studio which is awesome
um so i had to play a lot of games that
i've never heard of that are um very uh
new from debut studios
and a lot of those by the looks of them
i'm like this is kind of uninteresting
and then i now play them and
i end up loving them um the one that
really got me was the falconer uh that
is i think an xbox game plus game that's
how i got it in any case
where you ride on the back of the falcon
and there's dog fighting and it's this
big open map and i was like ugh dog
fighting it's just like not my kind of
game at all but i ended up really loving
it i still haven't finished it um i i
will though i returned to it pretty
frequently but you just you fly a falcon
and you shoot stuff and you like explore
this world and try to get new locations
and you learn about these factions
because the different episodes of the
story have you playing as different
factions um repeating the same things
against each other would not have
guessed when i played maybe the first
hour for the purposes of the uh award
street i was like look just not into
this and then
i couldn't stop like it just happened so
fast and i was like oh
perhaps am into this george
corvallian said what's your favorite
ending in a video game i constantly go
back and forth between the last of us
and halo reach i think the first last of
us has one of the best video game
endings of all time halo reach obviously
also fantastic i would say the first
bioshock but it's funny
when you replay it the um would you
kindly moment actually doesn't happen at
the end of that game it's actually a bit
beforehand and the final boss fight is
much less cool but i do feel like it
realistically is probably the last of us
that is such a good ending
that is so upsetting and just sticks
with you and weighs on you and makes you
think for a really long time um it
really is brilliant enrique rave 82 said
how do you feel about the gta
re-releases
um the remasters yes
this one's disappointing um so i've been
really excited about vice city i'm still
gonna play by city it seems like they
this could all be misinformation i do
not keep up to date with gaming news as
much as i used to i feel like i'm way
more up to date with actually playing
video games but a lot less up to date
with gaming news i like
don't spend time on the internet really
anymore like i don't browse i don't use
twitter very much um
it seems to me like what they did was
port the mobile versions of those games
and thus there are a number of issues
with them um
frame rate problems a lot of bugs like
from what i've been seeing i've not
tried to play any of them yet but
that's definitely disappointing
however the minute that they removed the
older versions from the online stores
um to me it seemed like it was a take
two move and not a rockstar move that
take two probably wanted this rather
than rockstar pushing for this in any
capacity
uh take two have a lot of um
shareholders that they need to please
and have been kind of bragging pretty
openly about how many games that they
intended to release and i think this is
kind of what happens when you go out of
your way to try to release um whatever
it was like 300 or something 100 i don't
remember video games in a really small
span of times you have to kind of
scramble and this kind of thing is going
to happen and that is why
the stock market um
really influences the way that publicly
traded companies uh uh
function obviously what a redundant
sentence i just said yeah i'm ultimately
unsurprised um but of course it's
disappointing
that that really sucks i don't think it
will affect
what happens with gta 6 uh
though it is really hard to guess what
will happen with with gta online being
that it is still just so goddamn
profitable but that's so huge
but i'm hoping that what this means is
that that was like a well we're gonna
re-release these to make money and that
that's clearly what that was for it was
not for like the love of the fans or
whatever and that that lets rockstar
continue to make a very expensive video
game in gta 6 that they had to like give
them something so that they get
something so they can justify probably
absurd cost and time that is going into
gta which i still think will be a fair
way away
but yes no matter what
it is obviously
disappointing however for a publicly
traded company that was bragging about
how many
games that they were going to release to
their investors
i'm not surprised still a massive shame
aaron keegan said hi alana what games
would you recommend for adult casual
gamers my wife got really into animal
crossing and plays potty games with the
family but i would love to get her
another game that will capture her
attention like acnh did i'd love your
perspective and suggestions thank you so
this depends on the person i don't know
your wife but uh the game that i always
recommend to non-gamers that has had a
100 success rate for me is arkham asylum
um because it's batman people understand
it um that combat is a really good
gateway to other video games because it
feels so cool but starts off relatively
simple but like it looks
so complicated when really it's just
press x or press y at the right time to
begin with in that game the later ones
get more gadgety and a little bit more
complicated i mean even arkham sound
gets more complicated but it's it's
something that looks really cool that is
a more hardcore game
but it's still an easy introduction and
and characters that they know
um and the beginning's so cool and
creative that i think it really grabs
people of course they have to be able to
use jewel sticks which is still a
problem but like some casual gamers
don't know how to do that but if she
played animal crossing uh she would be
fine with that one so that it that is
always my go-to of course the sims is a
great one as well though people really
love the sims
burr said i'm probably too late to you
to answer these questions your next
gaming q a but here goes you're not
what are the
your thoughts on some indevelopers
complaints about subscription-based
services like game pass and ea play
cutting into their profits to give a
concrete example what would you imagine
the impact would be on a studio like
supergiant games of hades was only
available by a subscription rather than
as a standalone title you buy should any
studio sacrifice the additional funding
and skip over some of the fine tuning
and polishing that goes on in the end
stage game development if that means
they can avoid being included in
subscription services um well i actually
can't answer your question you said what
are your thoughts on some indev
developers complaints about
subscription-based services like game
pass and ea play cutting into their
profits
uh i obviously do a podcast here on this
channel with an indie game developer who
has been on game pass i'm friends with a
number of people who run studios that
have had games launched on game pass um
i've never seen anyone complain i have
no doubt that those people exist and
that that has happened but uh everyone
that i've spoken to about it has felt
very positively about it and i think
that your impression of it is probably a
little bit more simple um because they
don't just get profits
from
the subscriptions they tend to get like
a down payment
from microsoft it is still a publishing
deal um that is then put on game pass so
um for a lot of studios again i know
this happened with um descenders
specifically
uh which is a game that i found on game
pass they found that because of the buzz
that was generated by game pass their
sales uh after they were off game pass
were increased exponentially than they
were prior to being on game pass and i
guess the same thing happened to rocket
league like we all know rocket league
because the way that it launched on
playstation it was free
and you could argue that that would hurt
their profits in that month i'm sure
that playstation paid them to to be part
of the deal
but then it took off and continued to
make money long term so that wouldn't
apply to every studio but of the people
that i know the best that seems to be
the case is that they sell better when
they're off game pass
people are more likely to buy them in
the long run so um i ultimately don't
have
a lot of knowledge of the negative sides
i don't doubt that it's negative for
some studios just these studios that
i've spoken to about it or that i have
seen publicly speak about it
have all been very positive um
like for example if supergiant like your
example of hades are only available by a
subscription rather than standalone
it's kind of hard to say what difference
it would have made but i feel like it
yeah it could potentially have helped
them a lot and it's obviously on a
game-by-game basis and a studio by
studio basis who should go on and who
shouldn't
definitely shouldn't just be everybody
and that is it
for me today everybody
uh thank you so much for joining this q
a you can leave questions for the next
one and the one after that i've just
been pulling them from like two previous
videos in the section below the next one
will be a personal q a in about two
weeks so i basically just like answer
anything that doesn't have anything to
do with gaming so you can ask movies tv
whatever else and um thank you all for
joining me
i'm having a lot of fun making youtube
content right now obviously i'm in the
middle of moving i'm not fully set up in
the new place yet or anything so there's
a long way to go um but we're getting
there and uh yeah i don't know i'm just
having a lot of fun with the stuff i'm
making the two podcasts and even doing
the two monthly q a's and all the
gameplay stuff and my approach to it is
like
i don't feel like i'm making the most
original youtube content by any means um
not doing anything different to other
people but i'm really
enjoying it so thank you for
letting me have this really nice
positive fun
creative outlet i appreciate it i will
have dying like two gameplay up
this week um i was supposed to publish
it yesterday i just haven't had the time
to edit it yet which is obama
and i am also planning to have a chat
about the elden ring network test with
some of my friends who are
huge uh from soft fans so we're gonna
have that up this week too as like a
little podcast thing um
but yeah thank you
for watching this video thanks to keeps
for sponsoring the channel as always
i will see you guys next time bye